hey guys did you know that you can
improve the way that you look by just
choosing the right beard style for your
face type
it will especially look good if you
don't have a strong jawline or
chin all you got to do is just grow your
facial hair
so let me help you out let me give you
10 options let me show you 10
different beard styles that you can try
out let's not waste any more time
let's get to it
[Music]
i have a dream that's all i
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you hear my channel welcome my name
is daniel and if you haven't subscribed
yet please consider it and also click
that notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next videos
we do videos on fitness grooming style
and
life itself
[Music]
first up the short beer if you're always
shaving and you're not used to having
facial hair
then this is the beard style that you
want to go for if you want a more
rugged look then this will help you to
look more manly
just remember to keep your neck and
upper cheek hair trimmed
the stubble now this is actually a
tricky style to maintain because you
don't want to give people the impression
that you're just lazy and just forgot to
shave so you need to keep it trimmed so
shave off all the hair here on your
upper cheeks your
chin and maybe also your sideburns now
if you have a great
jawline this is a style that you want to
try
[Applause]
short rounded beer now this is really
not one of my
favorite but a lot of guys seem to like
it so i had to share it
[Music]
verdi now this is a classic and it looks
great on guys who want to look more
sophisticated it's named after the 19th
century
italian composer giuseppe verdi
now for the verdi you need time you need
8 to 12 months to grow the handlebar
mustache
and the 3 to 5 inch beard
[Applause]
the pencil mustache it's not really a
beard but it's a mustache and there's
only a few people that actually looks
good with it
i'm not one of them but you can give it
a shot
[Music]
the van dyke beard style this is really
a great choice for guys who have a
patchy beard
you know when you have that patches here
on your cheeks and you don't really like
it
well why don't you just cut it off and
go for the van dyke
style some guys look really great with
this style it's like
they were born to wear it
[Music]
the full beard this beard takes patience
and also the right products
it's all about grooming your beard to
perfection
and remember to wear it with a stylish
haircut like a short
side part with fade now remember if you
don't keep your hair styled
as well so it looks great with your
beard you don't do it
you can just it can just look like
you're lazy and that's not what you want
but if you do it right you will have a
great look
[Music]
the power beard with a trimmed mush dash
this is a great look
that you can just keep well groomed
the mustache for example cannot go over
your upper
lip keep it short and then of course a
big bonus is that you won't have any
food going into your
mustache oh man biggest enemy
of guys with beards toothpaste
and food
[Music]
the viking beard did you guys watch the
series
vikings ragnar lothbrok
man the vikings caused a whole new beard
trend
and yes the viking look does look cool
[Music]
the corona beer most of you guys know
about hashtag corona beer that's been
trending on social media for a long time
and even now
it is still popular with a lot of guys
covet gave us an excuse to just
grow at our beards and it is accepted by
most people they understand it because
after all
lock down right the idea behind it is to
just
let it grow and that's it now just the
last tip
always remember that your hair style and
your beard style
the two of them they work together as a
team to give you the perfect look
your beard style is not gonna look good
with just any hairstyle
so if you need more advice on hairstyles
and hair products all of these things
and also
maintaining a well-groomed beard check
out one of these videos
and i'll see you there cheers guys